I'm not for abortion oh shut up [ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm not for it but I'm not against it
easy it all depends on who I get
pregnant
I don't care I don't tell right now I
don't care what your religious beliefs
are anything if you have a dick you need
to shut the [ __ ] up on this one series
this is there's the right to choose is
there unequivocal right not only do I
believe they have the right to choose I
believe that they should have to consult
anybody except for a physician about how
they exercise that right gentlemen that
is fair and ladies to be fair to us I
also believe if you decide to have the
baby a man should not have to pay
that's fair if you can kill this
[ __ ] I can at least abandon them
it's my money my choice
[Applause]
and if I'm wrong then perhaps we're
wrong
[Music]
my mom said for kids you can tell that
she loves us all the same bar for the
first two she kind of stopped caring
she'll always gonna buy she was blessed
with me then she was gifted with my
sister then she had my brother and
she'll always remember the day that she
was diagnosed with the other one
we were all in tension although which is
good my mum's has a very healthy elder
to contraception which is great because
her sister is anti-abortion which is a
cruel nickname but she's had five
I'm surprised to see what that they let
me do that your immigration I don't I
got kind of I don't have a there's too
many people in this [ __ ] country but
I think if you're gonna focus on keeping
people out you gotta focus on the people
who don't contribute to society that's a
no-brainer but and there's a specific
group of over four million people they
come into this country every year and
don't contribute a [ __ ] thing and
everyone knows who I'm talking about but
no one wants to say it cuz it's
politically incorrect but [ __ ] that you
know who I'm talking about officer Bob
you know what I'm talking about
who am I talking babies that's who I'm
talking about babies they come out of
your hole they come into this country
they don't speak the language they don't
wanna work they just take and they take
and they cause a ruckus and they waste
all of our natural resources I say put
the Border Patrol agent at the foot of
your uterus anything comes out without a
b c and kick it back in the hole
what's your name well you're not on the
list get back behind the velvet rope the
club is over full we'll call you when we
need you sick the amount of people Oh
Doug don't you do it an aunt that baby
bid on every CD yes cuz you won't stop
having them so I'm gonna keep saying
almost every problem in the world
boils down to too many [ __ ] people
and I'm not just talking about of my I
had my mastectomy I have no children
anyone else had a vasectomy who did did
you go get him a drink that's a true
American Hero right there don't name the
bucket Memorial Highway after him after
he gets thing after that guy every time
you get a good parking space there you
go that you can remember that guy yes
next he's the guy who didn't have summer
Park in there every time your fur gets
stuck in traffic yeah you think about
the breeders when you have no traffic at
all today in America for instance
abortions legal it's beautiful that
abortions legal man yes beautiful I love
going to abortion rallies to pick up
women cuz you know that [ __ ]
so you ain't gonna find a bunch of
virgins after the abortion rally you
might even see some clear
oh the abortion issue Manson woman's
issue
I wanna get pregnant chilling there [ __ ]
from the man [ __ ] you I don't need to
[ __ ] you unless she decides I had
the baby then she's like with my check
that's right when the woman gets
pregnant
is it choice between the woman and her
girlfriends I want to get pregnant
ha no girlfriends get together and they
have a little abortion tribunal and they
vote on the baby like it's survival and
each girl from puts in her two cents the
one girl for goes child you should have
that baby that man got some good hand
it's wavy it's wavy and the other
girlfriend goes child why we even
talking about this ain't we posed to go
to Cancun next week hearing that baby
and that's how life is decided in
America now fellas if you get a woman
pregnant you're only allowed to say two
things two things and guess what fellas
you can't even suggest the bush if you
say uh you [ __ ] up
you can't even suggest the bush and
guess what guys you don't want to
suggest abortion because if you suggest
abortion and then she has the baby when
that kids about five six years old he
gonna be cursing your ass out you go hey
what's up little man how you doing man
I'm alive as Hannah [ __ ] up doing
you wanna be dead huh [ __ ] I should bust
a cap in your ass you don't need that
trouble so do not suggest abortion now
fellas if you get a woman pregnant you
only got two things to say two ways to
try it now the first thing you can say
is Wow
I can't believe you're pregnant I'm so
happy I can't wait for you to have this
baby
I love you so much that's cool
now if you don't want to say that you
got one mo choice a woman walks in the
room tells you that she's pretty you
look good dad nah and you say so what
you gonna do
[Applause]
I'd say how you can solve this abortion
thing right now those unwanted babies
that women leave in alleys and in
dumpsters leave about 12 of them on the
Supreme Court steps this is over like
that you guys said we have to have them
well then you guys raise up man you
[ __ ] raise up you raise up you say I
had to have it the jerks pop sure why
why why why is it that most of the
people who are against abortion are
people you wouldn't want to [ __ ] in the
first place
boy these conservatives are really
something aren't they they're all in
favor of the unborn they will do
anything for the unborn but once you're
born you're on your own
pro-life conservatives are obsessed with
the fetus from conception to nine months
after that they don't want to know about
you they don't want to hear from you no
nothing
no neonatal care no daycare no head
start in the school lunch no food stamps
no welfare no nothing if you're preborn
you're fine if you're preschool you're
[ __ ]
[Applause]
conservatives don't give a [ __ ] about
you until you reach military age then
they think you are just fine just what
they've been looking for conservatives
want live babies so they can raise them
to be dead soldiers pro-life pro-life
these people aren't pro-life they're
killing doctors what kind of pro-life is
that what they'll do anything they can
to save a fetus but if it grows up to be
a doctor they just might have to kill it
they're not pro-life you know what they
are they're anti-woman simple as it gets
aunt enrollment they don't like women
they believe a woman's primary role is
to function as a broodmare for the state
pro-life you don't see any of these
white anti-abortion women volunteering
to have any black fetuses transplanted
into their uterus is doing it you don't
see them adopting a whole lot of crack
babies doing you know that might be
something Christ would do and you won't
see you won't see a lot of these
pro-life people dousing themselves in
kerosene and lighting themselves on fire
you know morally committed religious
people in South Vietnam knew how to
stage a goddamn demonstration then they
knew how to put on a [ __ ] protest
light yourself on fire come on you moral
Crusaders let's see a little smoke to
match that fire in your belly here's
another question I have how come when
it's us it's an abortion and when it's a
chicken
it's an omelet
[Applause]
are we so much better than chickens all
of a sudden when did this happen that we
passed chickens and goodness named six
ways we're better than chickens see
nobody can do it you know why because
chickens are decent people you don't see
chickens hanging around in drug gangs
Diane you don't see a chicken strapping
some guy to a chair and hooking up his
nuts to a car battery do ya when's the
last chicken you heard about came home
from work and beat the [ __ ] out of his
hand doesn't happen those chickens are
decent people well let's get back to
this abortion [ __ ] now is a fetus a
human being this seems to be the central
question well if a fetus is a human
being how come the census doesn't count
them if a fetus is a human being how
come with is a miscarriage they don't
have a funeral if the fetus is a human
being how come people say we have two
children and one on the way instead of
saying we have three children people say
life begins at conception I say life
began about a billion years ago and it's
a continuous process continuous just
keeps rolling along rolling
listen you can go back further than that
what about the carbon atoms
human life could not exist without
carbon so is it just possible that maybe
we shouldn't be burning all this coal
just looking for a little consistency
here in these anti-abortion arguments
see the really hardcore people will tell
you life begins at fertilization
fertilization when the sperm fertilizes
the egg which is usually a few moments
after the man who says gee honey I was
gonna pull out but the phone rang and it
startled me
[Applause]
but even after the egg is fertilized
it's still six or seven days before it
reaches the uterus and pregnancy begins
and not every egg makes it that far
80% of a woman's fertilized eggs are
rinsed and flushed out of her body once
a month during those delightful few days
she has they wind up on sanitary napkins
and yet they are fertilized eggs so
basically what these anti-abortion
people are telling us is that any woman
who's had more than one period is a
serial-killer consistency consistency
hey hey if they really want to get
serious what about all the sperm that
are wasted when the state executes a
condemned man and one of these pro-life
guys who's watching comes in his pants
here's a guy standing over there his
jockey shorts full of little Vinnie's
and Debbie's and nobody's saying a word
that I guy not every ejaculation
deserves a name
yeah speaking of consistency Catholics
which I was until I reached the age of
reason
Catholics and other Christians are
against abortions and they're against
homosexuals well who has less abortions
and homosexuals leave these [ __ ]
people alone for Christ's sakes there is
an entire class of people guaranteed
never to have an abortion and the
Catholics and Christians are just
tossing them aside
you'd think they'd make natural allies
go look for consistency in religion and
speaking of my friends at Catholics when
John Cardinal O'Connor of New York and
some of these other Cardinals and
bishops have experienced their first
pregnancies in their first labor pains
and they've raised a couple of children
on the minimum wage then I'll be glad to
hear what they have to say about
abortion I'm sure it'll be interesting
[Music]
in the meantime what they ought to be
doing is telling these priests who took
a vow of chastity to keep their hands
off the altar boys
[Applause]
when Jesus said suffer the little
children come unto me that's not what he
was talking hate abortion protesters
they're so shrill and awful they think
babies are being murdered what is this
supposed to be like no it's not cool I
don't want to be a dick about it though
I don't want to ruin their day as they
murder several babies all the time I
don't think it's killed a baby I don't I
mean it is it's a it's a little bit it's
a little bit killing a baby it's a
little bit it's a hundred percent
killing a baby it is
it's totally killing a whole baby but I
think that women should be allowed to
kill babies that's what I think they
should be allowed to kill babies
[Applause]
we get to kill baby do some shots and
kill some babies I kill like far babies
last night is [ __ ] [ __ ] I just
think it has to be one of the other you
know like when people say abortion
should be legal safe and rare why ringer
if it should be legal if it should be
legal it's it's [ __ ] if it should be
rare it's farming babies